so we try to look at basically model
based planning
uh but with a
past uh official start time
all the people who were there in the
previous session haven't come back but
usually have some attrition after the
lunch break that's common
so i think we can just just start
okay so uh we left off with this
notation for the
two stage case uh so i'm just gonna go
over this again and then i'll make a
couple of comments about this versus
uh maybe an mvp setting uh so
uh we have n uh trajectories you know if
you're
in the clinical trials world of the
precision medicine world you can think
about this as being end patients
and for each one you have x1a1 x2 a2y so
x1 is baseline information it's a vector
of
baseline features uh and in fact you
know this doesn't
everyone here is being in euclidean
space there's some instances but it
might also be functional data or imaging
data and so on but
for simplicity i'll just assume it's put
in you have a first stage treatment
which is coded in zero one a1 x2 is
information you collect during the
course of the first treatment uh
and we'll see that's in p2 rp2 and then
we have a second treatment again binary
and y is the outcome or the utility
coded so that higher values are better
we define the history at stage 1 to be
h1 is just x1 and h2 as x1
a1 x2 and so we are not assuming
uh for example that y only depends on
let's say
x2 and a2 uh but it can in fact depend
on the whole history
uh it in the extension of what i'm going
to show you to multiple stages you still
don't need to assume that it's mark off
meaning that like stage three does not
have to be independent of stage one
given
the information stage two uh and
the way that we're gonna be able to get
past that uh is
by having a finite horizon obviously
with infinite horizon case if you don't
assume any kind of additional structure
it's kind of hopeless
because you could never extrapolate
beyond the observed period
so that's the setup here
and here we look at policies or
treatment regimes dtr's dynamic
treatment regimes pi
which are a pair of functions pi one and
by two one for each stage
where pi t maps the history of stage t
to an action or
a decision or a treatment so you know if
you're following pi and a patient
presented at time t with history capital
ht equals little ht
they would be assigned treatment pi t of
ht
and we're going to focus on
q learning so the optimal treatment
regime maximizes the expected outcome if
treatments are made according to pi so
i'll write e
superscript pi here i'm going to
suppress some of the oops just suppress
some of the causal different stuff here
we will talk a little bit about
potential outcomes you know if we get to
it later
but but here i'm just going to kind of
just use this notation to indicate
that this expectation is respect to the
distribution of y that's induced by
assigning treatment according to
pi and to characterize the regime that
maximizes this we're going to use the q
functions so here q2h2a2
is the expected outcome given second
stage history h2
and second stage treatment a2
and q1 is the expected maximized second
stage q function
given h1 equals little h1 and a1 equals
little a1
so this is the expected outcome for a
patient who's presenting in time two
with history h2 and is treated according
to a2
whereas this is q1 is the expected
outcome for a patient presenting at time
1 with history h1 treated with a1 and
then treated optimally in future
and we know from dynamic programming
that the optimal strategy the optimal
regime pi t
opt of ht is the arg max
over all treatments uh at q t h t
a t so uh seeing this representation
uh immediately suggests a strategy for
estimation so q two here
uh just the regression of y and h2 and
a2 so we can estimate that using
some kind of regression method and then
while we don't observe q2 we can plug in
an estimator
say q hat to here and regress that in h1
a1
or the maximization of the maximum
maximized q hat too
and so that's exactly what we're going
to do so we're going to look at q
learning
and here you know the distinction should
be made that
when i say q learning i'm talking about
this sort of regression-based dynamic
programming thing
which i'm going to present which is you
know what is
typically used in statistics and in
biostatistics
uh which in contrast to you know
uh watkins and dyan you know kind of
usual q learning
um so it's similar in spirit uh but it's
this is obviously finite horizon so uh
just to make that distinction
uh and also we know we have continuous
states and so on but
uh the idea is the same so here
is some some q a going on about sort of
treatment regimes versus policies uh
is it just a terminological distinction
and also like this regime come from why
why are these called regimes does it
just come from regimen like for
treatment something like that
oh you guys are testing testing my my
history here so the
the the term the terms mean the same
thing that's that's the easy answer so
uh uh policy or treatment strategy or
adaptive treatment strategy a treatment
regime or dynamic treatment regime
all mean the same thing the
term treatment regime i think goes back
to jamie robbins
and uh i don't know
what the what this i think i mean uh
both robbins and and and murphy used it
early
uh i don't know why they chose regime
there's others who then push for regimen
because they thought you know regime
sounded like some kind of oppressive
government or something
so they tried to get a regimen but i
think regime stuck the term dynamic
is sometimes it actually refers to the
personalization so the one
stage stuff would still be a dynamic
treatment regime because it's
personalizing
whereas a static regime is one that's
not tailored to individual
characteristics
so unlike every other setting on earth
dynamic does not refer to changing in
time
it refers to changing the treatment
recommendation uh so it's dynamic in
that sense
so that's a little i think that's a
confusing point
uh in terms of the terminology that's
used
uh but yeah i don't know where the well
i think when it was first used there
wasn't much cross-pollination between
cs and the stats world it was mostly
causal inference people
looking at longitudinal observational
studies and so they came up with their
own terminology
so i don't think that it was really
bridged until later so
i mean the connection between rl and uh
dynamic street regimes
so thanks yeah thanks
uh so okay uh the regression based
dynamic programming so what do we do we
posit some kind of working models for
the q function
say q t h t a t of beta t so the q
function stage t
indexed by some parameters beta t h t
zero transpose beta t0
plus at ht1 transfers beta t1 so here
ht0 and h21 are just fixed feature
vectors constructed from ht so they
could include polynomial terms or they
could include other basis functions
uh and uh at is
just this interaction term so if you
look at this you can see that the first
term doesn't have a treatment in it
and the optimal treatment according to
qt is going to be the
uh it's going to be 1 if ht1 transpose
beta t1 is positive and
zero if it's negative okay so in order
to estimate the q functions we use least
squares
so i could get beta hat two to be least
squares estimator so pn
y minus q2 h2 a2 beta2 squared so just
do these squares it gives you beta hat
2.
and then for the first stage you're
going to plug in the maximized estimated
second stage q function here so you see
this is the max over a2
this should be little a2 that's typo q2
h2 little a2 beta hat 2. that now
becomes the response and then you're
regressing it on this linear model here
for the first stage
so this is just if you look back here
we're just plugging in
the estimated q function here and then
regressing it on h1 and a1
so it gives us beta hat one and then pi
hat t of h t
is the arg max of q t h t a t beta hat t
okay so it's really just you know two
regressions in a maximization so very
easy to implement and to define the
sort of targets for inference the
population parameter is beta star t
well to find those is what you get if
you just replace these empirical
expectations
with the true uh expectations the true
population expectation so replace this
with a p
so this would just be the projection of
the outcome on q2
and then you would plug that q2 in here
and look at this projection of q1 and
that's how we're going to define these
population parameters so again we're not
assuming the linear models are correct
we're just going to assume that that we
are are going to try to conduct
inference for those projections
and we're going to focus on confidence
intervals for some linear combination of
beta 1 star
the reason is that beta 2 star this is
just least squares here this is just
leaf square so inference for beta2star
is straightforward
you can instruct a wall type confidence
interval do the bootstrap or any of
those things would be fine
normal approximation so we're going to
focus on beta
sorry beta 1 star which is where the
non-regularity plays a role
and why is there going to be
non-regularity well we've seen this now
a number of times it's this max operator
this is where things are going to to be
problematic so this max is
non-differentiable
and that's we're going to get that
instability just like we had with the
max of means and just like we had with
the indicator in the value function
okay so the non-smooth max operator
makes beta hat one non-regular
uh the distribution question just
so why uh
why may not be the conditional mean of y
might not be linear
in h2 uh
right right and so that's why you say
projection
but now whatever it is once i estimate
beta 2 then my
u2 is linear right so in the next
equation
um the nonlinearity just comes from the
max variable that that's the only reason
it's a project
like you're projecting to linear
functions because q2 is already a linear
function right
oh this is this this thing okay two
things one that this would be
this term here would be a linear
function of
h2 and a2 yep then you take the max and
now it's no longer a linear function
because of the max right so if it was
like uh it would be the positive part
so the max of q2 will be the positive
part of ht1
transpose beta t1 so that won't be
linear anymore
right okay and that's then pulled back
into the linear space by this
second least by this term yeah and then
also
even if even if we we put some kind of
um
i don't know even if it was somehow
linear and some basis functions
uh it may not be linear in h1 and a1 it
may only be linear in h2 and a2
but not linear in h1 and a1 ah i see
because i'm now regressing on
each one thanks
sure thanks uh okay
see i'm losing my mouse here
okay so uh the consequence of beta hat 1
being now regular is that the
distribution of c transpose wrote in
beta hat 1 minus beta 1 star
sensitive to small perturbations of the
generative of the underlying generative
model p
and also the limiting distribution does
not have mean zero so often we think
about you know
these kind of things having mean zero
that's what we call asymptotic bias
so uh of course there's always not
always but there's often finite sample
bias but
asymptotically the mean of this is not
zero
uh and this typically occurs when we
have small second stage effects meaning
that h21 transpose beta
2 1 star can be small or
more accurately i i should say that
eight there's variability
of h21 transpose beta hat t1
when h21 transposes beta star 21 is
close to zero and we'll
see that in a theorem in a second uh and
why is that well because that's what
this max operator here
is only affects the second term and the
max of this thing is going to only be
non-smooth where this is zero
that's where the point of nine of
differentiability is going to occur
uh and we'll see we'll formalize that in
a second so
uh as we've hopefully have now been
convinced confidence intervals based on
series approximations bootstrap and
before poorly
and so one of the things that was sort
of put forward
uh early was to apply shrinkage methods
and i want to talk about whether or not
those
have the intended effect oh
sorry uh question was what's txt uh oh
treatment sorry yeah i will sometimes
write txt for treatment i tried to fit
this on one line
so uh yeah treatment second stage
treatment effects
uh okay so try to reduce the asymptotic
bias to shrinkage
uh or to form conservative estimates of
the tail probabilities of
this quantity which is what we'll also
talk about
okay so i want to talk a little bit
about asymptotic bias reduction so we've
been talking about kind of distribution
approximations let's talk just about the
mean for a minute
so given some constant vector c that is
the same dimension as beta 1 star
and some written inconsistent estimators
say beta tilde one with beta star 1. so
it could be least squares it could be
something else
because we're going to talk about some
alternative estimators in a second such
that written
beta 1 tilde minus beta 1 star converges
to some
distribution m
and then we'll define the c directional
asymptotic bias
say bias of beta tilde 1 c to be the
expectation of c transpose m
so it's just the just the expectation of
m transpose c
or c transpose m in a standard problem
this would be zero
uh but here it is non-zero and in fact
you can actually work out what it is
uh for q learning assuming all the right
moments exist
for any c the bias of the least squares
estimator the one we just talked about
the direction of c has this form
uh okay so there's a lot of pack here
but let's just see what's going on so
there's
uh c transpose times some kind of
covariance term
uh so here i've just combined the first
stage regressors into a single vector b
b1 and so this is the outer product
expectation of the outer product b1 b1
transpose
uh and what you see here is that
the bias is driven by this term here so
i mentioned this idea of these effects
being small
so first let's work backwards indicator
h21 transpose beta21 star is zero
so we see that it's those patients that
have zero treatment affected the second
stage that are
driving this bias and it's weighted by
this term here
which is actually the variance of uh
there we go it's actually the variance
of h21 transpose beta hat21
right so you get this quadratic form so
what's happening here is that we're
going to get very large bias
if we have a lot of variability in h21
transfers beta hat21 among those
patients
that have no effect
so uh now that we've managed
so okay the reason that's important is
that a lot of the bias shrinkage methods
try to reduce the variability
of h21 transpose beta hat21 around those
patients for which h21 transports beta
start to an equal zero
that's their strategy because the idea
is if you can drive this variance down
and then we see that this bias is
actually an average of c transpose
sigma 1 infinity b1 taken with respect
with the weighted average with these
weights if they can drive these weights
down then the bias will go down that's
the idea
uh and so they're in particular going to
try to shrink h21 transfers beta hat to
one when they think
h21 transfers beta star two and a zero
so that's the idea try to reduce this
bias
okay so maybe i'll just pause here
because there's a lot of
symbols on the side and take any
[Music]
questions
okay so you have this bias
which means that if you take the
limiting distribution it doesn't have
mean zero
and so one of the ideas to reduce bias
is by some kind of shrinkage and the
idea is that if you can reduce the bias
then you you look at a confidence
interval it might
have better coverage because it's
centered at a better place
so chakraborty at all with its soft
thresholding uh moody at all it did hard
thresholding goldberg and song looked at
some kind of lasso penalization
and there's been some other more recent
methods but the idea is the is
more or less the same the idea is that
if we write max q2 uh
with our model with beta hat plugged in
we get h20 beta hat to zero there's no a
here so it doesn't
affect this term plus the max over a2
and zero one of a2 transpose h21 beta
hat t1
and that becomes the positive part of
h21 transfers beta hat t1
and so this is what max q2 looks like
and this thing of course
looks like a you know a hockey stick
something so it's it's
got a kink in it and so that's where the
non-smoothness comes in
and so what they're going to try to do
is shrink this thing towards zero when
they think it's close to zero so it's a
little bit like an adaptive lasso or
something similar
so in particular uh the soft thrush
holding method replaces
this positive part with a positive part
times this term in the braces
so it's times one minus sigma h21
capital sigma hat21 h21 so this is the
the estimated variance
divided by n times h2 one beta hat two n
squared okay and sigma is a tuning
parameter one minus this so what's going
to happen here
[Music]
well if uh h21 transfers beta h21 is big
right if it gets really large then uh
this term here is going to to um
go to zero and we just end up with what
we had before right
and in particular you know if you let n
get large and this term is not zero then
this term is going to dominate because
this is going to go to a constant
right on the other hand uh if this term
if h21 transfers beta starts with zero
then this thing is going to converge
to a normal distribution squared or
basic some kind of chi-squared
distribution
uh and so this one this ratio will not
be zero
and we're multiplying this term here by
something less than one
so that's the idea and the amount of
shrinkage is governed by
sigma which is some tuning parameter
greater than equal to zero set it to
zero you just get back the original
estimator
uh and the penalization schemes i
mentioned this they reduced this
estimator under certain designs
and there's no theoretical justification
in chakra boarding at all but they do
show improved coverage and bootstrap
intervals in some settings and same goes
for these other
references and there's been some recent
work on smoothing
in this similar vein okay so what can we
say about about this approach
so it turns out that uh you can actually
work out exactly what this bias will be
for the soft threshold in the estimator
uh so if you let c again be a fixed
vector and beta hat one sigma denote the
soft threshold in the estimator that
means you do q learning but you plug in
a soft threshold estimator in place of
the second stage q function
when you do your first stage regression
then assuming all the right moments
exist you can show the bias
of this soft thrush holding is always
less asymptotic bias so soft
thresholding is always less than
the asymptotic bias of q learning less
than or equal to
for any sigma greater than zero and if
the bias is non-zero so if you're
understanding when you do have
asymptotic bias
then you can actually work out what the
ratio of the of the asymptotic bias is
so the bias
saw thresholding relative to uh
just a standard estimator has this form
so e to the minus sigma over 2 minus
sigma times the integral from rip sigma
to infinity 1 over x e to the minus x
squared
so if there are any students taking you
know an
intro stats class or recognizing this is
like some kind of normal integral that's
that's where this comes from and
what you see is that if you let sigma go
to infinity this thing goes to zero
uh so importantly you know you have this
lower bound here uh so more shrinkage is
better
under a fixed parameter asymptotic
framework right so everything here has
been fixed
so uh so the question is is it really
useful so it seems that
this this seems to suggest that it would
be right um
uh not only is it better but also more
is better chakra body at all suggests
sigma equals three
uh so if you plug that in you find out
that that ratio
ends up being a 13-fold decrease in the
asymptotic uh
bias so it's a huge reduction in bias 13
times
uh however so bias is not a
number right you define it's a number if
i fix a direction
[Music]
1340 interesting
fact that this does not depend on c over
here oh
yeah the c cancels which is kind of neat
i guess the definition involves the
direction but yeah
you're right yeah that's right the
definition involves the direction but
once you take the ratio of the c
cancels uh which is
maybe surprising um
uh okay yeah so that's a good point i
should have said that that's a good
point yeah so
uh so the ratio will be it will be 13.
basically we plug in sigma are
approximately 13.
uh however this is based on these
pointwise asymptotics
and so may not actually reflect finite
sample performance so let's see what
happens if we look at this through a
local asymptotic framework
so now we've seen all this and so
hopefully this is not so so horrible
uh we use local asymptotic approximation
as before
so for any local parameter s of the same
dimension as beta 2 and star
we're going to assume there exists a
sequence of distributions pn so that pn
is converting to p in a sense uh and
that the important piece is that beta21
star n meaning the least square is
the the the part of the second stage q
function
interacting with treatment that that
coefficient
under p n is equal to the one under p
plus some local perturbation
uh where beta two and star is the
argument it's just the least squares
estimated under pn
so again we're going to look at things
under this local perturbation and we're
going to try to study the asymptotic
bias
where we look at these local
perturbations the generative model
and if we do that just and it's just
related to the thirteen four i mean
thirteen four but like what what is the
what is the magnitude of these
quantities
i mean how how
maybe you show us an example later but i
will show you a plot here uh
in like three sides oh okay
uh okay so if we look into this local
generative model
and we take the super local
perturbations
of the asymptotic bias of the original
estimator
it's bounded above by some constant k
okay so
no matter what perturbation sequence i
take the asymptotic bias is always
bounded
but if i take the soft threshold in the
estimator and i take the super local
perturbations
it diverges to infinity as the amount of
shrinkage increases
so what this is showing is that if you
if you try to do this shrinkage
it can be infinitely worse than doing
nothing
uh in small samples and what this is
sort of suggesting i guess i should say
it's local asymptotic approximation and
this is not super surprising
uh in the sense that we know with super
efficient estimators you
you you have results like this uh where
you know it appears to be doing much
better but then if you look at sort of
uh local alternatives the the risk goes
to infinity or you have other kind of
problematic behavior
but uh so so here uh
there is no free lunch we can't just we
can't just shrink aggressively of course
that makes sense because if we over
penalize we're shrinking that term to
zero for everyone
um or let's say we go to infinity we
would be shrinking that second
term and our seconds hq function to zero
uh
so then there's this issue of well okay
fine so too much is bad
but zero doesn't seem great either so
maybe there's some way to construct a
data-driven choice of sigma
that somehow leads to good performance
no matter what the data are
and i'm going to try to convince you
that that may be true but
it's very difficult and probably not
worth it so
uh to do that consider data from a
two-armed trial so you have treatment
ai and outcome yi no covariance
treatment zero
one uh
sorry if you can hear my kids screaming
i apologize they are uh
killing each other i think but i they're
both screaming so they're both still
alive
uh okay so uh
why is is codous the real values better
higher
the higher values are better to find mu
star a to be the expedition of y given
treatment a
mu hat to be just the sample mean under
that treatment
uh and the mean outcome of the optimal
treatment assignment then as we've seen
alcohol theta star here is the max of
museum e1 so back to our max of means
problem
and the corresponding estimator theta
hat which is the max of those two
uh i guess i should have put a
zero here instead of a star but it's the
same estimator uh it's just the max of
the two means which i can write as mu
hat zero plus the positive part of mu
hat one minus mu hat
zero so if mu hat one is greater than mu
has zero this term is just mu hat one
minus mu not zero which can't so the
mean at zero cancels
on the other hand if you had zero is
greater than you have one the term side
here is negative
so the positive part zero we get back
and you had zero and the soft
so the reason i wrote it this way is
because you have a term that doesn't
depend on
treatment in a positive part so it
mimics what we had before
it just looks just like our q function
so the soft thresholding estimator in
this case would be
mu hat zero plus the positive part of mu
hat one minus mu had zero
one minus four sigma over n you have 1
minus mu hat 0 squared
so this is the equivalent estimator in
the simple problem
okay so now uh here's what
the bias looks like
i'm looking at showing you the bias uh
here
uh and it's color coded so green is good
red is bad and bias goes from zero to
two
uh here the the y axis is mu one minus
mu zero so the true difference
and i the amount of uh variability here
is chosen so that
uh minus one to one covers
uh i think you have very little
ability to tell where you are in here
based on the estimator so that is to say
the the a confidence interval i think
would have a range of about
three or four in the setting based on
how i chose the residual variance
and so you really don't know where you
are in this band so if you if you get a
mu hat one minus mu head zero
you don't really know where you are on
this band you might be at zero
like if your point estimate was zero you
wouldn't know if you're really at one or
minus one
and on the x-axis here is sigma
so this is the true difference in means
this is the uh
athens this is the the amount of soft
thresholding zero is no thresh
no no uh shrinkage five is a lot of
shrinkage
and three is what was recommended by
chakraborty at all
and so what you see here is that if the
true difference was zero then
it gets slightly darker green as we move
across and so you should you should pick
sigma as big as you possibly can which
makes sense because the difference is
zero
uh but if the difference were say minus
point five then then the amount of
trinkets should be
quite small say somewhere in here 0.2
maybe
and if you were to pick three then now
you have kind of a lot of bias you have
a bias of about
uh one so
that that would mean that the bias is
twice as big as the difference in
magnitude
uh between mu1 and mu0
and similarly you know if the truth were
one
and then then you should have basically
no bias but if you chose a value of
three as recommended
you'd be uh pretty severe bias 1.5
and and so on so uh so that okay fine so
n equals 10 is the sample size i'm
showing you here that's uh
pretty extreme so what happens if n
equals 100 so and if that equals 100
then of course uh we have a much better
sense of where we are in the scale so we
have a mu hat minus mu 1 will give us
much more information about mu 1 minus
mu 0
so we'll probably likely be in here
somewhere but if you zoom in
this is the picture you get and it's
exactly the same
right once you zoom in and you can you
and you classify the uncertainty here
uh in terms of like uh this is about the
same amount of confidence you would have
for n equals 100 you you could basically
say if it was really zero then you would
really have information that was between
whatever minus three and three that's a
confidence interval would
easily would cover that uh now you're in
the same situation again so in terms of
of what you should choose it's not clear
so if i just tell you you're somewhere
on this lawn
between minus three and three what sigma
should you choose
uh you'll probably come up with
something pretty small if you want to be
safe
right obviously you can do better if you
had more a
more accurate estimator that difference
but you don't um and so
it's really a game you can't win
essentially
or or if you're going to win the amount
of bias reduction you're going to get is
going to be quite small
so uh the point here is that the
variability of mu hat minus mu 1
prevents identification of the optimal
value of sigma because you don't know
where you are on this line
is the variability and using a plug-in
estimator could lead to large bias so
you could you know the truth could be
zero your estimator can be one
say you're here you have submitter could
be or minus one and
uh so you you um
you plug in a small value and sort of
miss out here but if your if your true
difference was minus one and you were at
zero
right so your point estimator was zero
but the truth was minus one so you say
oh have a ton of shrinkage you could
really pay a huge price down here
right so data-driven
uh choice of sigma then significantly
improves asymptotic bias over no
shrinkage is difficult
so i i don't have an impossibility
results but um i think it's a very hard
game to win
uh and it may not be worth it and we
know it could be infinitely worse if you
do it wrong
so does that answer your question ambush
did you ask before
yes but i still want to make sure i
understand so
this bias that you're talking about is
not that is it at the scale of 1 over
square root 10 so
so it's we still have consistency but
the issue is
that once we take one over square root n
times the difference of the estimator
minus
the true that limit has some nonzero
mean
yes right yeah scale the biases of order
one over n
yeah okay and that's a problem when
you're constructing confidence intervals
that's right which is why we're worrying
about this okay exactly yeah
because they're shrinking at right one
over at n so
yes that's a significant bias yeah
definitely that's good thanks
and these shrinkage methods i mean i
have seen them and you mentioned lasso
like in the high dimensional setting
but here it's not high dimensional right
this is extremely low dimensional yeah
right right
but the
and so and so there there's there in the
in the
other case i mean you're incurring so
much estimation error too
that you the shrinkage buys you a lot in
terms of mse here the purpose is
different it's supposed to be
to reduce asymptotic bias uh
yeah got it so the reason why you do
shrinkage is actually very different
yes even though the method might look
very similar oh i do
soft thresholding we do in either
dimensional models also we're doing it
here but the reasons are
so yeah i just want to make sure that's
separate
that's right yeah
um okay so asymptotic bias is exists in
q learning again it's because there's
non-regularity
local asymptotics show that if we shrink
too much uh
it's conveniently worse than doing
nothing which is not that surprising
uh data-driven tuning seems to require
choosing sigma to be very small or
risking a very large bias
okay so now i want to talk about about
confidence intervals
so you know even though we have this
asymptotic bias we can still construct
uh consistent confidence intervals and
we can do this by bounding so
so the bounding will cover those local
perturbations which will also cover that
bias and so we can still get
um regular uh
athletically correct confidence
intervals and so we're going to
construct our bounds now and c transpose
written beta
at one minus beta star we'll bootstrap
those boundaries at a confidence
interval
uh it will because we're taking those
super local perturbations it'll be the
tightest among all regular bounds
uh which gives us that automatic
adaptivity that we mentioned before
uh this is also known as local uniform
convergence
you can also get conditional properties
so robins and ronitsky
uh showed that um
and you can also get global uniform
convergence which i'll say something
about
the end okay so how do we get a bound
well first what we do is we take
what the c in in like application c
would be
like it would be an indicator like
you're only doing inference on a
coordinate
oh c c c could be it could be uh
just a unit uh standard uh like a
canonical
uh unit vector you know like one and one
component
zeros everywhere else it could also be a
h1 if you wanted to look at the q
function
for the for the first hq function for an
individual
it could be just a a contrast
for example to look at um a difference
in in
say two components like what would
happen if you change something yeah yeah
it's usually one of the coefficients so
so one of the components of beta 1 star
or the predicted value for an individual
given the first stage history
[Music]
okay so to to get these bounds uh
on c trans so we're going to derive a
upper bound on c transpose written beta
hat minus beta beta one hat minus beta
one star
and the way that we're going to do that
is we're gonna write v n c gamma
to be the sum of two terms and uh
which is going to be this decomposition
here essentially uh
c transpose s n so this is some smooth
term and i've given it here
so this just comes from literally
writing out the definitions of these
you end up with a term here that's p n
minus p of a bunch of
fixed random variables so the central
limit theorem is going to apply these
are going to be asymptotically normal
so s for smooth plus c transpose sigma 1
inverse p
n u of gamma so now u is for
non smooth on smooth uh so
u n here is b1
times the positive part of h21 times zn
plus gamma
minus h21 transpose gamma so here zn is
going to converge to a normal
distribution
but this gamma is now kind of playing
the role of a local parameter
an additional parameter and it turns out
that if you plug in
uh beta star here beta beta21star for
gamma you reduced
exactly down to this quantity
so the way in which we're going to get a
smooth upper bound is going to be by
suping over these terms here these are
going to be the local perturbation terms
so i think eric you already explained
this to us i mean you started the talk
by saying that there is none
in non-regular situations you have
problems and
uh but now here we are back to talking
about
regular bounds i think there are some
questions on zoom about
just maybe reminding people like why are
we worrying about regularity
and what is a regular bound just because
this is a little bit unfamiliar
yeah that's right okay so what what's
our goal yeah let me go back and say
this
so the idea is is similar to what we did
in the first two sections and that
we can't bootstrap this thing we can't
use a normal approximation for this
so we want to do is we want to sandwich
this thing between two smooth bounds
that we can bootstrap or use a normal
approximation to consistently and if
this is a parameter for stage one which
which has
non regularity due to the max over a2
that's right
that's exactly right yep exactly so
uh yeah because yeah because the max
operator that's used in dynamic
programming
this term here uh is non-regular meaning
that it's sensitive to local
perturbations generative model
and so one approach would be to use a
projection interval by first
constructing a confidence interval for
beta2
50 star and then working backwards that
way
we're going to use the bound based
approach because it's less conservative
in this setting
and so what we we're going to do is
construct
and ultimately our goal is confidence
intervals for components of beta 1 star
linear combinations of beta 1 star
so we're going to take this quantity
we're going to bound it between an upper
bound that's smooth and a lower bound
that's smooth then we're going to
bootstrap those bounds take the
percentiles
and then solve for c transpose beta 1
and get a confidence interval for it
that's the idea and so we're the way
that you get these bounds is by looking
at local perturbations of the generative
model
and taking a soup over all those all
those perturbations take an upper bound
and an inf to get a lower bound and so
this is the building block so i'm going
to show more here but this is the
building block for constructing that
upper bound
here basically you take this this term
and you decompose it into a smooth part
and a non-sweep part this is the part
we're going to work on bounding
and i've taken where the local parameter
is going to show up and replace it with
a gamma
because in the next slide we're going to
take a super gamma and that's going to
smooth everything out
so uh let me go to the next slide and
sort of see if that helps clarify things
a bit
so we can show that root n c transpose
rho n beta hat minus beta 1 star
is v n c beta 2 st 1 star so if you plug
in a beta 2 and star into this
expression
you get back this quantity and so to
construct an upper bound what we're
going to do is
we're going to take unc this oh geez
uh i did not need to promote unc here uh
they're our enemies but um
anyway so uh unc is c transpose
that's the smooth part with leave alone
then for the non-smooth part we're going
to use a pre-test
as we did before and this pre-test
is going to say if h21 transpose beta's
2 1-star
is far from zero so you think about it
as testing this null here
if it's far from zero then just leave it
alone plug in beta two and star here
but if it's close to zero so this test
statistic is small then take a super for
all gamma
of this term so this will be an upper
bound because
this soup is over all of our p and if we
were to plug in beta 2 and star here
then you'd have the same term within it
with complementary indicators so you
would just reduce down to
exactly this
okay and to get a lower bound you can
you can take an inf instead of a soup
so the point here is that that this is
indeed an upper bound and also that the
soup smooths out the now it's smooth
functional
and it does that by by taking all the
local perturbations and taking a soup
over them
and then we bootstrap the bounds to form
a confidence interval so
uh let me just formalize uh
what's happening here in terms of local
alternatives so
if we let c again be fixed and we assume
a local generative model with local
parameter s
then under sufficient moment conditions
uh we get the following limit for c
transpose root n beta hat minus beta
star
and the form of this obviously this is
hard to look at
so let me just point out the sort of
really the salient parts here so we have
a smooth limit we have another normal
limit here this is just an average
over some features and a normal random
variable everything here is
is fine there's no s's here so it's
regular
then we look at the second part this
comes from the non-smooth part we have
h21 transpose z infinity this is a
normal
a gaussian random variable random vector
plus the local parameter
minus h21 transpose the local parameter
and we have these positive part
functions
okay so again we see this local
parameter showing up
and it only shows up among those
subjects that have zero second stage
treatment effect that's where that max
operator was non-smooth or
non-differentiable
and so this again confirms that this
quantity here is non-regular
but if we take the upper bound that we
constructed
and take its limit the first part is
exactly the same so if you compare the
first line here
the f of 2 with the first line of one
you see that those are exactly the same
so
so the smooth part is left alone
but the uh second term instead of having
these s's we've now taken a soup over
gammas
which is equivalent to taking a soup
over s's so we've taken a super
all over the local parameters and so
uh this is regular because it doesn't
depend on the local parameters so we
stooped over them
and it's also clearly an upper bound on
this term
okay so to get a lower bound again you
take an n if you just have an inferior
okay so uh this is our our regular upper
bound we also have a regular lower bound
and then to do inference we are going to
bootstrap that so
given a level alpha and some fixed
vector c
let l hat and you have to note the alpha
over two and one minus alpha over two
percentiles of the bootstrap
distribution of the balance meaning
we bootstrap this quantity here so we
resample from the data and compute this
thing
uh many times and take the percentiles
to quantiles
uh and those are l hat and u hat uh so l
hat would be the lower percentile of the
lower bound you had the
upper percentile the upper bound and
then
let pm denote the distribution with
respect to the bootstrap weights
okay so so uh the randomness induced by
resampling the data
then under sufficient regularity
conditions moment conditions
and conditions on the pre-test and for
any epsilon
the probability the conditional
probability given the observed data
under the bootstrap weights
that c transpose beta hat minus the
upper percentile of root n
is less than or equal to c chances of
beta 1 star as less than or equal to c
transpose beta hat 1 minus the lower
percentile of root n
this the probability that c transfers
beta star is in between these two bounds
uh is less than or equal to uh
one minus alpha minus epsilon uh with
probability uh
or the probability that that uh it
misses rather
uh has error more than more than alpha
is going to zero
so just to unpack this a little bit
confusing so this is the probability you
cover under bootstrap
you want it to be at least one minus
alpha so you're saying the probability
that its coverage is less than one minus
alpha minus from small epsilon
that converges to zero so it's saying
the coverage
uh converges to one minus alpha of the
there's bootstrap there's a question
eric about um
sister continuing to to understand this
concept of regularity or its absence
can it actually be stated at some kind
of
stability you mentioned how like small
changes in the generative model
can generate like abrupt changes in the
limited distribution so that actually
seems like some sort of loss of
smoothness and i don't know if it's
formalizable in some
in some bloodsheds or some stability
type of way
so the way it's formalized is if this
limit contains s
so if so to go back to this assumption
if you generate data
what was that assumption here if you
have a if you have this sequence of
contiguous generative models
so you have something like this uh
if under that generative model the limit
depends on the
local parameter then that's that's the
formal definition so which is what we
see here the fact that this s shows up
under that model that's how we know it's
non-regular
but then there's this question of like
is that does that mean um
uh so it's the only way to figure out
that it's not smooth to sort of go
through and compute the limiting
distribution
uh i think formally but generally if you
have a non-smooth
well okay let me just be clear there are
settings where you have a non-smooth
let's say operation with the data where
everything's fine like uh
if you were doing like mean absolute uh
if you had absolute loss or something
right
if you have a convex function but it's
not differentiable uh that can still be
okay right
so uh there's various m estimators that
are that have a non-smooth loss function
where everything is fine
uh so the the thing that
intuitively the thing that screws things
up is when you have estimated things
plugged into non-smooth functions if you
have an estimated quantity
plugged into an announcement function to
do that that's when you have a problem
and so here we have this sort of bellman
backup that has a plugged in estimated q
function in it
and then the max operator is applied to
it that's sort of the red flag that
you're going to end up with the problem
but the formalization is this
is there an impossibility theorem that
that because because if it is due to an
estimator earlier you said that in the
max of means problem this is unavoidable
people have shown like
you just can't get around by just
playing with other estimators it is that
still going to be true for like let's
say these two stage problems that
no matter how we change now no matter
how we are clever about plugging things
in
this non-regularity is not going to lead
us that's right so this is another
example where there is an impossibility
results
and the impossibility result comes if
you look at the
at the s demand right if it's an if it's
a non-smooth functional
degenerative model in some appropriate
sense and the reference there is van der
vaart 1999
uh then uh and then there's toronto and
porter i also cited earlier
they then it's then then you cannot get
a regular estimator
so but the exception
is it when it is when you use it you you
can you can have a smooth
i said this once before but i'll say it
again this is the
if the s demand is not smooth then
you're in trouble there's impossibility
results that you can't get
something that's asymptotically unbiased
you can't get a regular estimator
but there's also the case where you can
have a regular s demand and estimate it
with a
problematic estimator and still get down
regularly that way
so in this case because q1
is non-smooth functional the generative
model there is no estimator that's going
to save you
uh but if you have an s demand that is a
smooth functional
you could choose an estimator where you
still have a problem
if that helps so here there is no
there's nothing you can do in terms of
choosing a better estimate
and there was a comment that maybe can
be replaced max by absolute but that
that doesn't help either right because
absolute values are also
yeah yeah that's exactly what you would
get if you had
i coded the treatment as minus one one
instead of zero one
and in which case what you'd have here
instead of a positive part you just have
an absolute value
and the limit would be exactly the same
okay
yeah so you still have this you'd saw
this issue
and the upper and lower bound method for
dealing with this problem
is that's what you recommend as opposed
to let's say the projection idea
like in practice this is a better thing
to do
yeah so we ran the projection on this
and and this
uh in this problem and the coverage was
uniformly won in the
interval itself was i had to forget how
many times bigger but it was
much much bigger yeah to the point where
we didn't i don't even think we included
in the paper because it was just
so wide that it was um
yeah the projection uh
way of computing intervals is just uh
like a
textbook thing that you teach to but i
mean but it's never useful
i think it i think in the max of means
case it's not so bad
uh and i also think it's a great way to
start because then you then you can say
okay well
now i have something that actually gives
the right inference can i then make it
adaptive somehow
and um i think once you make it adaptive
it can be very close to the bonding
approach
uh yeah so i think it's a good i think
it's like
it's a good starting point
a good tool to get yeah like it's kind
of like assuming everything is normal
and nicely behaved and you're trying to
develop a new method and then you work
out what it is then you say what if it
wasn't normal what if
you know yeah i think it's like the
first step
um okay i wanted to just
sorry also like maybe clarify what
what's you and and maybe people in this
field mean when they say adaptivity
because it activity again like it's just
like
dynamic it has oh yeah sorry so so what
i mean is
if you're in a setting where action
where where the generative model is
suspect you could have used a bootstrap
or you could have used
a normal approximation and everything
would be fine because you're
away from that point of non-smoothness
uh then you want your method to
automatically recover either the
bootstrap or series approximation or
something that's going to be exact
and then and then what you really want
is a method that targets
to the extent possible only the parts of
the problem
that are not smooth so like in the bound
here
you know you can see that we have this
kind of smooth part that's left alone
and then we only have the soup affecting
the second part which is where all the
for the local parameter shows up in the
original limit so the idea is that we
shouldn't be messing with this part
or any adding any conservative in this
first part
any conservatism in this first part
because we don't need to
that's the that's what i mean by
adaptive
so there is it possible in this example
line two um
uh previous slide so could the proc with
the real data generating distribution be
such that the entire second thing
doesn't play any role
yes situation
uh if you had uh all all
patients had uh treatment effects
bounded away from zero at the second
stage all patients had
icic in that case
yeah that's right
uh so this is this is i always wanted to
present a result that
[Music]
it's not mine uh but i i tinchang wu
who's at
was it wasn't michigan uh and this is
the result that he arrived and i
thought it was really nice uh this is
and so i wanted to present this
and it also is one of the things about
these bounding approaches is that you
can sometimes get
conditional coverage and also uniform
coverage uh for free
well i mean if you're willing to do a
bunch of proofs but i mean it sort of
comes
sometimes comes automatically without
adjustment uh so
uh what he showed was that given a level
alpha
and vector c and l hat and you had just
the bootstrap percentiles as before
the bounds pm again is the bootstrap
distribution
then under moment conditions and
conditions on the pretest
then for any epsilon greater than zero
we have the same theorem as before
the bootstrap prob the bootstrap
coverage the probability that's less
than one minus alpha minus epsilon is
going to zero
but if you take the worst case coverage
over p uh it still uh covers
so if you take uh
that is you're taking the inf over the
coverage here as a function of the
generative model
uh it still covers over a very large
class of distributions and i'll refer
you to the paper to see that class but
um
so you do there was some there was there
was some mention of you know uniform
results over distributions and this is
one of those cases where that happens
uh and so i just thought i would i would
show that
um there's a nice result from chinchon i
don't know if you ever published this or
not i think it's in this dissertation
so uh so that's that's a nice bonus of
these bound based methods
you can also often show that they give
you conditional coverage
um meaning that if you conditioned on
the rule you also get correct coverage
um so i'm going to skip over the these
uh simulation experiments
and just let you look over them uh if
anyone's interested in
your own uh because i wanted to skip
ahead to
a little bit of discussion and then i
think we have a break so
uh break very soon actually i mean
we're already in the break but we
started a little bit late so maybe a
couple more minutes
okay so you know what i'm going to do
i'm just going to skip to like what does
this have to do with infinite horizon
problems let me just say that
uh because i think there's so we've
looked at
no stage problems one stage problems two
stage problems and now
uh you know a lot of the things that i
think
we see in the usual rl world are like
you know mvps infinite horizon problems
so i just have two quick hand-wavy
slides about what does this have to do
with an infinite horizon case i want to
show how the bounds work
in this case so suppose you have data
from a homogeneous mdp and i'm not going
to say all the regularity conditions you
need for an mvp
but you have you know state s one
action a1 and so on you suppose you
observe these trajectories up to some
time point t
so it's an infinite horizon problem but
you've observed data up till time t so
it's a batch
you observe a batch of data these nit
trajectories
i equals one to n and e is that
uh the treatment is it has there's some
behavior policy
that's used to generate the actions of
the treatments
uh but they don't have to be completely
randomized
but but they they assume they they have
to have non-zero probability of
assigning each
action well we'll assume that for now
yeah
and you have some utility ut which is a
function of state
action and next state uh so st is a
state and a t is the action here i've
coded at minus 1
1. and suppose you're looking at the
discounted reward case and you posit a
linear working model for the q function
say q s a beta is phi s transpose beta
and suppose you're going to estimate
beta hat by solving this estimating
equation so this
uh you'll recognize uh from gree greedy
gq
uh also see this paper by uh ashkahn
and uh eterfe and ron schroderman
uh so essentially you have
uh average over the subjects sum from t
equals 1 to t
utility plus the maximized next stage
cube this is this is a t plus one so
this type of t plus one
beta minus phi s t transpose beta v st
so this here is a t plus one so that's a
maximize next stage q function
this is somebody asked about absolute
value well this shows up
so now now what do we do how do we use a
bound for something like this uh
so what you do is you um if you look at
some algebra
you can show that this quantity written
beta hat and minus beta star is in fact
a root
of uh vnh beta
so root in in an h of this
quantity here so something that is
normal and smooth that depends on beta
star
plus something that's going to converge
to a constant matrix so that's
phi phi transpose times h plus
a sum of gamma that's a discount factor
fee of st plus one transpose root n beta
star plus h
minus gamma phi of s t plus one
transpose red n beta star
bst okay so
this is a p dimensional uh equation if
you find its root you get back this
so now what do we do well uh
if we want to bound given any c suppose
i want a confidence interval for c
transpose beta star
i want to construct a smooth upper bound
on c transpose written in beta hat minus
beta star
i do that by taking the soup over some
set of local perturbations script sn
c transpose times a set of all roots so
this is not standard notation but
root h means the root of v n h
s in terms of h so
uh then this has to be an upper bound
because i can plug in
uh beta star for s so as long as sn
contains beta star
i get back this thing so it has to mean
upper bound on this
and it turns out that if you choose sn
appropriately you can bootstrap this
thing you construct its quantiles you
can get a
lower bound by taking it in and so this
is how you can use all these ideas
you know in the infinite horizon case
now in terms of like
if the hero here i've kind of made it
easier by looking at iad draws if you
just had one long continuous draw
then what you'd end up having is you'd
still have this sort of normality but
the way you would argue it would be
through some kind of
martingale central limit theorem type
thing instead of just a regular
central limit theorem so here i'm
letting n diverge
if when i write zn saying this is
atomically normal i mean it's n diverges
you can do the same thing as t diverges
but it's more complicated
but the point is as because it's an
implicit root we can we can construct
upper bounds this way
and that's how you that's how you can
get inference for beta
and also just to make it clear
the fact that you have this absolute
value term here
and this root end b8
beta star that's what's going to signal
the non-regularity here because if we
replace this
with uh let's say beta star n which is
like uh
some local perturbation that
perturbation is going to remain because
we're going to scale up our red end so
it'll show up again
so okay so maybe i'll stop there for the
break
uh oh so there's uh can we generalize
the infinite horizon bound approach to
more complex actions
uh we can definitely generalize it to
so so right now i would say i can
definitely generalize it to
any finite number any finite action
space
the question is what about a continuous
action space
and there the answer is maybe i think it
will depend on the form of the q
function that you use
uh what it will look like so i mean i
think conceptually you could do it i
haven't sat down and tried to do it so i
don't quite know
having a continuous action space might
that actually
alleviate some of the problems with
non-regularity
maybe i don't know i might might smooth
things out somehow
sorry maybe then like max over a nice
enough continuous set doesn't give you
weird behavior or do you think it's so
generic that it's just
genetically the problem will be there
even if you go to continuous actions
i don't know yeah i mean there is maybe
it does smooth things out somehow or
or something uh i don't know yeah that's
a good question
but i don't know offhand yeah
and and and you were giving some not a
definition but you were giving some
intuition about when
non-regularity manifests itself oh by
the way i should announce that
officially
are done so people want to take a break
should feel free to take a break
um we start at 2 pacific and 5
eastern um eric so yes
you're giving this intuition that just
having a non-smooth
function it doesn't it doesn't signal
non-regularity because you could be
doing like m estimation with absolute
loss
so if if the non-differentiability
applies to data
and that's defining the estimator that
necessarily is not a problem but when
you plug in
an estimator into a non-smoke function
that's usually where problems start to
begin
is that really right yeah that's right
okay
and so in the previous slide let's try
just one previous to this one
um this is now sort of recursive in beta
right so so the non-regularity is still
there because somehow
the absolute on beta shows up in the
equation for beta itself
yeah that's right that's why that's why
it's that's why there's an issue
yeah okay
the part on bias i still don't like
what's the message like we should not
worry about that or because i didn't
like non-regularity i think i'm getting
kind of the feel for what you're saying
but the discussion on asymptotic bias
and the fact that
it's very hard to get rid of it by by by
shrinkage like
is there a message beyond that i wasn't
sure if i got the point
but i think what i was trying to say is
that we
it may not it's it's there and it's
significant of it but there
the the cure may be worse than the
disease in terms of trying to get rid of
it
uh oh okay is what i was trying to say
yeah so
it just live with it
yeah yeah constructive method that can
still work you know even if you don't
reduce that
because you'll pay a price in variance
or by making more bias than you started
with
yeah let me just quickly check this card
and then i'll let you
take a break all right yeah no questions
anywhere so i think we'll just reconvene
in 20 minutes
okay all right thanks oh wait no there's
one more
there is one more just came up
uh do i know of any companies that are
working on statistical rl
uh yeah so i think um i think
uh amazon is definitely getting into
this i think uh
obviously google has a huge presence in
terms of um
uh it's rl and i'm
certain there are there are many others
um
i actually was was doing some rl for um
delta airlines before well no one flew
anymore and there's no like
yeah there's no more problems there but
uh
yeah i think i think there are if you
want to send me an email um
i can try to send you to the right
channels in terms of of
finding a postdoc in that vein because
there's some pretty cool
problems and also you know they they're
there there's real problems showing up
in places you might not expect i think
uh so you know i mentioned
some of the ones in the beginning but
just um
people are starting to realize that like
just because somebody doesn't have a ton
of data volume that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't be quantifying information
gain and we're starting to see
more more uh maybe this is my own
bias but i personally have become much
more interested
in sort of the old experimental design
literature you know starting in the 40s
where they had very limited experiments
and they were just focused on maximizing
information because
that's what we're finding with these
really expensive rl type problems where
if you're going to make a decision and
it costs you a lot
then every just every action really
matters so it's not the same
type of problem as we would think okay
well if we're going to build a poker
player
or a chess bot or a go player right
then we need to be super computationally
efficient and also very clever in terms
of all the algorithms and so on but
uh we don't want we wouldn't be willing
to spend a day on computation
for each action in building a chess
player right so
it's a totally different problem in the
sense of how
information gain is weighted relative to
data volume because the cost of data is
so expensive so
i think that's the kind of a neat area
that's emerging in the industry
at least in my own little bubble um
you know against the business of
creating
confidence intervals and then worrying
about the bias and
regularity obviously this has direct
implications in like a setting like
clinical trials social behavioral
sciences because scientists are involved
and they want confidence intervals
do you think this is still relevant in
your in your consulting work with like
companies do they
do they care about this stuff so it's
surprisingly similar
to uh what i found is
that it that the experience working with
clinicians is what turned out to be
super relevant because
you know there will be some some basic
question where the
you know the expert wants to know like
uh
you know should we paint our science
pink you know we
we had to store it i mean this is not a
real question i don't think amazon's
ever painted their science pink but like
you know they'll supposedly they'll do
that at two stores and it looks great
and they'll say like
do we know should we do this everywhere
and also like if you build some kind of
forecast model
they want they want interpretation of
the coefficients you know it gets back
to like stat 101
only now maybe an rl world or like
how much better would my model get if i
run these experiments you're suggesting
you know
and can we get confidence intervals
around that and
so uh so there really is there really
are humans that you're interacting with
who have a lot of like deep expertise
in the application area but then you
know maybe don't have the experience in
rl and they want to make
use of that so there's a communication
issue and a
kind of transference of expertise
somehow or something
um so yeah so i mean that that
it ended up being strikingly similar uh
so i know people are doing uh this is my
own little soapbox i tell my students
this all the time
because everybody not everybody but
there's sometimes some some interest in
doing the coolest
latest fanciest things and then you go
out and you realize that the right tool
was like uh
some some solid classical kind of
techniques
um so we have to keep both of those in
in
mind somehow uh anyway
i mean the classical tool set is
classical for a reason right
yeah that's right yeah i think there's
some sort of will you you listen to the
process that sort of kills over time
methods that didn't find a wide variety
of use
yeah that's right they they have
survived so they're
we're running our own like uh i don't
know evolutionary algorithm in their
research space
and sort of spawning our little children
and then some of them survive
and then others are just lost to time
yeah it's it's actually very interesting
to hear
that um that yeah like in the industry
also that
they want like these kind of guarantees
because maybe too much it
is at risk and
i i mean i have my own selection bias
which is like those are the kind of
problems i'm likely to somehow
be directed to right i mean i'm
obviously people doing like uh the
advertising stuff and the search stuff
you know and maybe like uh recommender
systems for music and movies and
whatever
i'm sure they're doing um really
classic not classic but at least you
know more conventional type rl or banded
type stuff i would think
um but even when i was at google uh
i you know ended up working on
you know a lot of people working
advertising but i ended up working on
like data feed quality evaluation over
time and so like um
that was again one of these like rl
sequential decision problems were
actually the amount of
the actions the number of actions were
very small uh
because you're looking at like i don't
know maybe you have like 10 providers of
data and you want to sort of evaluate
their quality
space and time and then decide what you
should which ones you should go with
and so even you know so even in these
companies that are known for like
big data and big horizons and stuff like
they have those kind of problems